foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I wore a tie welcome to the world's most
dangerous show and not just because of
what I'm wearing under this
it's because this is the most honest
thing you're gonna hear on TV this past
weekend an LA crowd of about 50
criminals decided that Nordstrom might
be Swedish for free stuff roll it
the crowd ransacked the shop stealing a
hundred grand worth of designer Goods
wait a minute this is not the right
video that's Chicago from last week
that's the mob that looted to 7-Eleven I
didn't think Nordstrom sold beef jerky
you roll the right one please go ahead
all right so in La last week 50 criminal
wait a second that's not La either that
is that's Philly
that's 100 kids took a Wawa apart that's
the last time I let you guys smoke weed
at the production meeting
let's try it again
so out in California
for God's sake who's working the video
today kill Mead that's California but
it's from Glendale last week when a mob
looted 300 Grand from an East Saint
Laurent store
all right
all right there's Nordstrom
that was long by now though you do get
the point I mean this video looks so
familiar Hunter Biden should hit on it
oh
another mob another ransacking the only
difference this time security guards
tried to intervene but the thieves used
bear spray to drive them away bear spray
I guess that'll be locked up now as well
and thanks to those jerks law abiding
citizens won't be able to get the spray
they need
Jody what's a good word huh can you
believe this bear spray is sold out
everywhere and my Nana's birthday is
three weeks away so if you'd ever need
to use it though right I mean bear
attacks are the most rare occurrence on
the planet
good luck thanks for the honey yeah
spray
[Music]
didn't see that one coming at all
anyway I also had a front row seen
myself to scenes like we saw this
weekend during the 2020 Summer of Love
when thieves decided what they actually
loved was ransocking ransacking shops
I'd never seen that level of criminality
and Lindsay Lohan lived in my building
so you got to wonder what causes all
this organized looting we go to the
expert I bet they got to go out and feed
their child and they don't have money
they're put in a position where they
feel like they either need to shoplift
some bread or go hungry that night
well that's dangerously stupid
so here's the scary part why is it that
when a largely white attended event goes
bad it's one and done and I don't mean
my last birthday party when Tom shallou
jumped out of the cake
take Charlottesville that's largely
white I if I remember and it was gross
and disgusting did it repeat nope there
was Universal revulsion and condemnation
just like my honeymoon
the same thing though happened on Jan 6.
what made that so bad was that it was so
jarring an exception to the rule for any
Dems that might have tuned in by
accident it lasted six hours not days or
weeks but what about other events with
racial components that turn violent as
in looting Bobs it's a story so common
we could just replay old videos why is
this so common because it's obviously
being imitated people in general will
imitate Behavior if it's incentivized
and allowed so let's compare in
Charlottesville Condon Nation right not
incentivized and so not imitated the
2020 Floyd riots incentivized by refusal
to criminalize despite billions in
damage and at least 25 deaths you got a
future VP setting up a bail fund for
looters money that should have gone to
hiring her a speech coach
and so it continued imitated the point
being the media and its acolytes cannot
deny blacks their right to imitate bad
behavior while they inform blacks that
imitating productive behavior is selling
out to the oppressor why are black youth
enraged or encouraged to imitate only
bad behavior you don't see literally
coaches showing their teams endless
clips of the Mets
[Laughter]
I didn't write that joke I don't know
anything about baseball so don't don't
come in me over this
there are people leaving in Mets jerseys
hey they'll say it's about systemic
oppression whatever that's less a policy
than a fortune cookie and with this
Administration there's really no
difference sometimes I think they get
most of their ideas from Panda Express
but blaming the oppressors as always are
all whites means one cannot or won't
accept them as worthy of imitation which
is sad because boy do you miss out on
the Excellence of individuals but if you
only use the group filter of the presser
versus oppressed you can't see
individuals and how they act and Achieve
which makes it impossible to imitate
their good behavior will there still be
injustices of course and that sucks but
you don't let it own you instead use all
the tools you learned the things you
imitate from others who are successful
to reach success I guarantee right now
Jimmy Kimmel is watching a rerun of my
last show for the 58th time
and asking how the f is this dwarf doing
it
that's imitation
but it's only the media academic complex
who assume that blacks as a group can
only follow bad examples and that
assumption guarantees more young black
folks will do it because doing anything
else is seen as embracing Whitey but we
need to expand their Horizons their
choices their examples for excellence I
mean all you hear about is the carrot or
the stick when in reality I prefer a
carrot the size of a stick and then beat
looters with it
[Applause]
if this is what pain looks like call me
a masochist suppose I'm making money at
Fox Business Charles Payne
she suffered five years at the People's
Republic of ESPN oh kick host Charlie
Arnold
his safe space is a Goodwill donation
bin founder of the loftusparty.com
Michael Loftus
finally parents tell their kids to
finish their dinner because there are
starving people at Fox
news contributor
thank you
Charles great to see you you look as
Dapper as always thank you and I feel
bad for Michael Loftus because this is
what real people dress like
I love that suit thank you thank you
you've got a fill the fabric super 150.
don't you don't want him to touch it
what do you um why isn't this stopping
what do you think of my theory that
imitation is behind this or do you think
that there's something else there's a
lot behind it and by the way I'm
surprised he came to me first on this
let me just tell you my quick my own
personal experience so I grew up around
the country around the world uh the
first part of my childhood is an army
brat my parents separated we moved to
Harlem in the 70s and I can tell you the
blackout in 1977 in New York City was
amazing
it was the my neighborhood was the
hardest hit looting and I get it I mean
I'm out there so you don't understand
I'm looking out the window and people
are stealing stuff that I wanted so bad
I see the guy running back out of block
with a Boombox I was looking at this
Boombox for four years for four years
I'm like oh my God you know so I didn't
there's a Woolworth that's three blocks
away for some reason they took the Timex
watch display which used to be about six
feet tall They carried it from three
blocks away and dropped it right in
front of my building
watches I'm like oh to this day I have a
fixation you should see my watch
collection it's true
so I get it that's it so the whole time
I'm asking my mom can I please go loot
please and she said no she kept saying
no you can't look
I finally in the morning when she fell
asleep I did go out for some crumbs it
was bad okay I went to Tom McCann's shoe
store down in the basement it was Pitch
Black I grabbed a big ass box I'm like
got something I've moved people grabbing
it I go up I open it up as those big
shoe horns you know
[Music]
hot in in these in in black
neighborhoods that you're oppressed and
this is okay
you know that this system hates you and
so any opportunity you get to exact
Revenge fine and you know it's not just
the media it's the education systems
everyone else is people who should be
trying to help you who are the ones who
are actually hurting you I I'm telling
you right now what's happening in this
country
politicians in general are seducing
people to doing this particularly black
kids it's heartbreaking it's scary but
it just shows it's just another example
along with the poor education
and other things that they do not want
black people to do well in this country
and you have to wake up to see who
really is on your side and who isn't the
people like my mom who said hell no
you're not going to go Luke is who you
want on your side yeah amen
Charlie
mayor Bass I think it's bass not base
who cares she said that this kind of
behavior is unacceptable but if it were
unacceptable it wouldn't happen haven't
the policies made it so that it's
acceptable you can go in there and steal
900 bucks well it's interesting because
you have some Mayors calling calling it
acceptable but then you have for example
the mayor in Chicago who won't even
refer to it as a riot instead calls it a
large Gathering which that's not a large
Gathering you know yeah like a barbecue
in your backyard for Labor Day yeah is a
large Gathering so it's interesting just
how politicians will address it because
some are so sensitive about being
considered a racist uh that they don't
want to you know say the wrong thing
Mayors though like this is what makes it
well that's the problem in Chicago as
we've seen just this weekend there was a
concert in Chicago it was Little Dirk's
concert I honestly have no idea what Lil
Durk sings uh but there was a warning of
an active shooter potentially being in
the building so people freaked out they
started running out of their seats and
most sensible people as you would
imagine in the situation like this would
run straight out the doors well there
was a lot of younger people people who
were there who decided just to start
raiding the merch stands so you're
seeing this in all different situations
I mean and in a lot of dark scenarios
dark merch and a lot of these scenarios
too what are you even stealing do you
even know what you like can you grab the
shoes I would not risk my life over Dirk
merch
imagine like are they comparing like oh
what did you get what did you get and
where are they released
where they're reselling it whether it's
online or somewhere else this is why I
always I make fun of Michael Loftus a
lot and God knows he deserves it but
in many ways you're a hero because no
matter how low your life gets or down
and out when you're living you know
crumb to crumb on the on the on the
highways with your little bindle on the
box cars yeah you never loot no not even
not even if like there's cans of beans
yes just lying by the side we don't it's
the hobo code
the Looting thing is it's it's it's
farcical now it's almost you know in a
weird way comedic and I've been waiting
to say this for a long time I've always
been so jealous I actually wrote about
this in my book neither stunning nor
Brave wow about the the mass lootings
because there are no consequences
there's not like you've got fat girls
looting now right that's insulting
they're not even worried about they're
gonna have to run they're like I'm gonna
hit Nordstroms hit the inhaler and then
hit the buffet you know um I I I don't
want to join in on this yes you do yes
this video we did it on the show of the
two the two giant women uh and the
assumption is that no one's going to
chase them right which is why some of
these stores here's what we should do
this is patriotic what you uh you put a
a plaque on the store instead of like
play like Champions anybody caught
shoplifting automatically enlists in the
Ukrainian Freedom Army oh
a couple dudes big girls put them on a
plane and go hey you want a trip to the
Ukraine you know I don't know if that's
constitutional cat uh she doesn't
believe in Lost
that's true no just not most laws what
do you make do you get the sense that
retail is dead when insurance companies
don't care well that's the thing you're
saying how does the Looting keep going I
don't understand how stores keep going
exactly because like store even before
all this stores passed their Heyday a
long time ago I'm never going to the
store it's just easier to shop online
but it's not easier to steal online so I
don't understand how like how how many
people are visiting the store to make
this kind of thing worth it the only
time I'm in a store is when I get
something online it doesn't fit and I
have to go to the store because the
store is at least better than the post
office which is like not a compliment
well the thing but then there you go to
the store if you're using cash right and
so there's a lot of people and those in
those neighborhoods I.E not your
neighborhood of course who I need cash
you have a credit card a lot of
neighborhoods don't have credit cards
they have cash I don't think those
people are using cash
but anyway no I'm talking about stores
the stores stay open in some
neighborhoods for people who can't go
online but uh I don't know but
everything's locked up now in some of
the stores yeah that's true section you
can't even get a frozen pizza well can I
add to the big girl thing yeah okay so
so I come out time again yeah and I got
nothing right I'm like ah boy you know
your shoe horn I don't know what the
hell would do with them I look across
the street at the singer store now no
one in my family so but what the hell
the gates are ripped down and I told
people running around I go into
Singapore there's nothing all of a
sudden the cops show up oh
right and they and they weren't
arresting anyone but they were whipping
ass yeah so they were just like
just I'm like oh boy also I'm like how
the hell did I get out here I saw this
girl see about 400 pounds I was like oh
and I just ease right out
she's like a tackle I was like and just
scoot it up that's one at home and went
home I said I learned my lesson all
right Mom you were right you know that
is so uh plus what do you call that body
positive what he just did
yes he was empowering that yeah
she saved my life she saved your life
and your birthday Heroes only here hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else